I have honestly been having a bit of
trouble making videos recently so today
I'm gonna try to ease myself back in
with something that's a bit simpler then
you might be used to I'm gonna tell you
about what I've been up to and stuff
fortunately though for your
entertainment purposes the stuff that
has been happening in my life recently
has been friggin weird it all started
when recently there's big national
newspaper here in the UK called The
Sunday Times did an article about me and
for some reason it ended up on 3rd page
which apparently lots of people read
they ran a story about the fact that I
recently hit a million subscribers on
YouTube which was lovely of them even
though I actually hit a million
subscribers on YouTube about two months
ago so it's a little bit late but still
lovely I actually made a video about the
article on my second channel yeah but
you didn't know I had a second channel
so well they don't click on that in fact
I never understand why people would put
annotations right in the middle of the
video you meant to be what you get
they'll put it there the end or
somewhere but yeah that Sunday Times
thing happened and then weirdly off the
back of that lots of news people saw me
in that newspaper and thought hey that
boy there he is news we should put him
in our new show I find it weird though
because for me I'm not news at all I
mean this thing that I do is just it's
just my life and I've been doing it for
like four years I don't know why people
would decide to pick it up now this way
this this whole experience has been I've
also found it extremely entertaining
probably not for the right reasons
either for example Channel 5 News and
ITV daybreak were apparently competing
with each other to see who would be the
first one to get a TV interview with me
it's completely understandable that news
TV shows we're going to get their
exclusives or whatever but I'm not an
exclusive Am I I guess I just find it
really weird because I don't feel like
I've contributed enough to the world yet
to warrant an exclusive anything I don't
know I just make videos on the internet
and I don't understand how this has
happened so I did the interviews both of
them took place here in my bedroom the
channel 5 one was a pre-recorded one but
the ITV one was live there was a camera
crew right here in my room broadcasting
to ITV one a terrestrial television
channel from my bedroom I just they
asked me to wake up like 5:00 in the
morning so they could come around and
set things up in my flat and then after
it was done I went to bed as well
because I never get up at 5:00 in the
morning but I woke up afterwards
genuinely not knowing if the TV
interview I just done was a dream or not
in fact if you could let me know if
you actually saw it that would be great
because it does feel like something that
didn't have happened and then on top of
all of that strange television stuff I
also started receiving lots of emails
from various people asking me to do
various things mostly interviews but
there was one email that I got today
which is just sort of amazing it's just
I'm not going to do this just so you
know in advance this is not going to
happen but the editor of GT magazine or
gay times magazine which is the
longest-running gay magazine I think
just ever asked me if I'd like to do a
naked photo shoot so I am NOT THERE
appropriate I think for looking at naked
because of many reasons I don't think
that I really look so that's the thing
that happened
hopefully the request for interviews and
stuff will slow down malla I've made fun
of everybody who's contacted for you all
so tomorrow I'm gonna start packing all
of my stuff up because we're moving me
and Alex are moving we've bought a house
together
oh they bought a house together because
I am moving out though I can tell you
now this is going to be the last time
that you see the wall of stuff 2.0
because I am going to be taking it down
tomorrow I know that saying goodbye to
this wall is going to be an extremely
traumatic experience for a lot of you so
what I've decided to do is show you a
time-lapse video of me taking it apart
bit by bit until it's all gone forever
it's time for the time-lapse
ah by then I guess you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool and screen it's the screen at
the end with the thing you can click on
if you want to okay good bye